I know
at least in North Carolina released
uninterrupted body camera video of an
intense arrest after public outcry for
excessive use of force this after a
local news Outlet reported the suspect
was pinned down by his neck no no no no
while the arrest happened on May 13th
Asheville Police Officers became
involved five days earlier on May 8th
when a 911
yes um
can you get
up on that street this this gotta stop
we have been calling about diving with
our they didn't serve the IVC on them
somebody's on my other line right now
I'm on mute they're letting me hear
Devin he's threatening to bust out more
windows at my mama's house I need
somebody to get over there
this is ridiculous
the caller explains the suspect is her
son 27 year old Devin Whitmire she
references an IVC or an involuntary
commitment in the state of North
Carolina that means a person has shown
signs or symptoms of psychiatric issues
or substance use and could be a harm to
themselves or others
I'm his mother and legal guardian and I
did an IVC but they never found them
and they somebody called me this morning
while I was at the hospital and said he
was they called the police on him
earlier on Long shows I don't know but I
wish somebody would please get this boy
whitmire's mother tells dispatch Devin
damaged her mother's home on Max Street
this weekend her window one of them and
I thought they were over there fixing so
obviously nobody's over there because
they saying he's standing outside
looking at her wings now I'm about to
tear our house up again this is
ridiculous we've called the police and
called the police tried to get them to
get this for him she also clarifies to
dispatch she's hoping officers will find
Devin Whitmire not her other son and
Devin's identical twin Tevin
when officers show up to the max Street
location Devin is not there but Tevin is
about 90 minutes later a magistrate
issues an open warrant for Devin's
arrest Asheville Police Department hey
this is
I've got some IBC paperwork that need to
be picked up and served but the person
has to be found first and the officer
who swore it all out is kind of standing
around I think he wants to keep looking
um let me tell you the person's name
you ready no yeah do you have any idea
where they may be located at we do we
have any idea where they may be
maybe about an hour ago we received
Street
sort of wandering around that way but
nobody's seen it since then during the
call the magistrate again clarifies the
warrant is for Devin not for his twin
all right what's his name
Devin d e these and Victor o n is a no
um with Meyer excuse me
w-h-i-t-m-i-r-e he also clarifies Devin
is dangerous before his controversial
arrest on May 13th Devin was arrested 24
times and had already been charged with
robbery with a dangerous weapon assault
by pointing a gun an assault with a
deadly weapon among others
really violent yes I would call him
violent and he's threatening to
kill various people around him five days
later on May 13th the officer who
interviewed Tevin finds Devin about a
mile away from where he was originally
seen blackmail white shirt looks to me
uh camo colored shorts currently wearing
a sling
foreign
body camera video shows the officer
approaching Devin who pretends to be his
twin brother
with Meyer
what's that
Devin
go on do you recognize me
no sir
do you um do you have ID on you
God because I know you I know you have a
twin
did you talk to somebody over across the
league
do you have ID on you
no no
to verify that you're that's what I'm
saying I just
that's what I'm saying I'm like what's
the problem okay this is my brother
doing something crazy
it's a type person the officer asks
Devin whether he remembers speaking with
him a few days prior you spoke to me cut
back about a week ago do you remember
this were you pulling me over I didn't
even pull you over
they didn't speak to me okay wow that
makes me feel like you're lying to me
because I spoke to Kevin okay okay
you don't remember that
where would you speak to my twin
you're Tevin so you I'm Tim and that's
what I'm saying like what like I don't
know where did you you did you just come
today yeah I'm just walking from down
there that's what I'm saying like what's
going on we're trying to find Devin so
he's in Lee Walker Heights doing all
that that's why I'm not up
there Devin continues telling officers
he's Tevin claiming he would not lie as
long as you're Tevin yeah
it's not that I'm saying you're lying
I'm trying to figure out what's going on
because he needs to answer his phone
he's going to find Devin that's it as
long once we prove that you are Tevin
then I will cut you loose okay
hey you seen my brother Devin out here
the police talking about he up here he
eat I'm trying to figure out what's
going on I don't need people telling
Devin that we're looking for him okay to
help you look at me I don't want people
to know that okay
people don't know why somebody stopping
me because I thought you were Devin
that's why that's why I'm out here I'm
looking for Devin numbers can I speak to
y'all can I speak to y'all whoever
whoever y'all got in charge yeah I have
no problem with that okay that's fine
I'm sitting right here
okay that's fine as long as you're Tevin
man you're cool I'm good with that no
because I need your bags at this point
you see that's uh the hospital put
Credence yeah I see that I see that I
just want to make sure that you're out
of 26. no I'm at the top
during the video Devin can be seen
wearing a sling the officer asks him how
he injured his arm a local news Outlet
The Citizen Times reported Devin's arm
was broken at the time of the arrest but
Asheville Police note that Devin does
not say that it's broken can I ask what
you did your arm me yeah he's drinking
about you
like there's nothing wrong with it
you're drinking and what you fail or
something yes sir the scratch how about
this one I bought this I bought this
from there and they said there was
nothing wrong but okay that's all I
wanted to know gotcha okay
his officers continue to verify Devin's
identity asking about his tattoos do you
have any uh tattoos on your upper arm
here yes sir
I'm sorry Philippians 4 13. okay how
about the other one I got new tattoos
I just found you so what's going on
so you've got Monique right there that's
a new one okay me and my twin have the
same tattoos
all right so what's going on
you have your ID on you no right here on
my armband
but my mother's not answering because of
what my brother's doing so like somebody
just ran down on Mega 21 Charlie 22.
if you have any tattoos that your
brother died
we're twins we used to get all our
tattoos inside
is there anything to identify you that's
not Devin other than that wristbands is
there anything else that we can use yeah
I used to stay right here and it doesn't
help I'm taking the meal with my name on
it what uh what other tattoos which mean
I have I have a lot of tattoos that's
Philippians 4 13 on my chair okay what
else do you have on your arms
for John 3 16 seem like much anymore
why are y'all questions I want somebody
to come out here
I want somebody to come out
whoever y'all got in charge because I
don't like it that's me officers then
speak with a woman standing nearby who
confirms she's Devin's fiancee it's your
car man
okay we'll talk to you in a second
okay
I'm not gonna say what's going on
do you have any tattoos
I'm not answering no more questions
again Devin asks officers what is
happening Oh no you're not telling me
what's going on well right now we think
that you would possibly get ahead okay
because you both have files and you both
have tattoos listed on your phone
how long ago did you get the Monique
tattoo
our verbal outside the business it's
been going on for about 10 minutes
was on your chest
yeah John 3 16 over I'm not answering no
more questions what's up officials
explain they believe he is Devin not his
twin brother and will take him into
custody when his identity is confirmed
all right so here's what's up so they're
confirming it right now but based on
your tattoos we know who you are and you
do have an ultimate for your arrest so
if that's confirmed then you will be
taking you down to jail tonight that's
when Devin says quote can y'all back up
so I can get my gun off me moments later
a struggle begins okay well can I can
back up
it's like where's your gun at don't
worry about it yeah
there you go
10 40. 10 40.
video shows the struggle continue as
Devin spits on officers multiple times
[Applause]
not
[Music]
he's not fighting
him
please stop he's not funny you have it
on video he's not okay
oh my God
you know you better give me that work
you know you about to give me that word
on the other side
right there
meanwhile the woman who identified
herself as Devin's fiance says he does
not have a weapon Devin says the same
thing
where's the gun that's why I'll tell you
they got one
I ain't got no gun
relax relax
let me know
I'm not kidding about it is he good I'm
not talking about it
still the officers continue to search
for a weapon where's the Gunner he
doesn't have a gun I tried telling y'all
that the first time
maybe you need to step back some
stop
relaxing
yeah
relax down
relaxing yeah coming up man hurry you
back
hey he grabbed my
relax grab my gun we're looking pretty
good
during this time a small crowd forms
people watching the altercation yell out
that Devin is being choked and cannot
breathe
we're not talking and we're not talking
them
Devin come on buddy
please
according to the Asheville Police
Department's report Devin continued to
resist until he was put in a squad car
as he's taken from the ground to the
squad a witness yells out to police
[Music]
thank you
relax relax
[Applause]
Can't Stop
the camera
Asheville Police note the department
petitioned a superior court judge to
release the body camera footage on May
19th and it was released on May 22nd
this request came after the Citizen
Times posted a picture of the arrest
with a headline quote white Asheville
Police Officers pin black man by neck in
releasing the body camera footage police
synced officers videos with the onlooker
cell phone video showing discrepancies
with the reporting
police point out the responding officer
positioned her arm between the pavement
and Devin's head so that she would not
put any pressure on his neck
steps
Asheville Police further point out that
Devin lifted his neck during this time
showing he was not pinned out
oh
them back
officials also release a side-by-side
contrast of body camera video and cell
phone video showing Devin kick at
officers during The Struggle No no no
in the end investigators determined
Devin did not have a weapon and it's
still unclear why he said he did he now
faces multiple charges including two
counts of assault on a government
official inflicting Serious injury three
official and three counts of malicious
conda upon review the Asheville Police
Department determined that officers
acted reasonably in the situation the
County District Attorney's Office also
determined there was no excessive use of
force right now Devin is being held on
85 thousand dollars Bond reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie